[Music]
I'm hugely optimistic at this particular
moment about the fate of the world so I
can't lie about that what I can say is
that when I was in a intense state of
grief and I had lost my son and my
spouse and my house within a two-month
period after the initial period of being
like I am effed like this is not gonna
be okay I'm I'm going down eventually
like finding little nibs little like
molecules in the air of hope about like
a little thing you know just like seeing
a friend I really loved and remembering
all the good times we'd had like over 30
years or whatever and then having like a
little spot of hope like maybe we'll
have a good time again at some point
like maybe well some other wonderful
thing just anywhere you can find a
little second of hope and feel grateful
for it and sort of dig into it that's
the way through the tunnel of grief I
mean that's not that that's what I've
heard from a lot of people who I've been
in communication with since this book
come out and people then write to me
about their experiences and come and
tell me that's how you live through it's
like you just find some hope and it's
like you just it's like a little tiny
fire and you go and just like until
you've got yourself like a little hope
fire going and then you can get through
well I think look I think that when you
lose a person or marriage you know or
suffer a trauma but the main thing I'm
think about is lost when you lose that
someone I mean first of all that's life
that's the price we pay to keep being
here as living people your that's the
human condition as you lose the people
you love and trying to sort of plow
through that and look for the good in it
I don't think that works I think the way
through
pain is is suffering it's like you know
leaning into the suffering and being
like I'm gonna actually go ahead and
suffer my guts out but throughout the
process moments of hope if you if you're
open to them they come and that's the
way that's the way to keep going is to
find like where where are their bits of
hope and how can you be grateful for
them and like feed them so that you can
find some excitement about staying alive
[Music]